well the rational God isn't the only
issue on the cabinet's agenda tens of
thousands of Israelis turned out for a
13th week of protests against the prime
minister's planned judicial overhaul
which Ben gavier supports Bernard Smith
reports from Tel Aviv
a tumultuous week in Israel Ended as it
began in Tel Aviv and elsewhere with
mass protests against government plans
to overhaul the Judiciary prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu and his Coalition
Partners from the far right want to give
politicians more power to appoint
Supreme Court judges they say the court
is elitist and intervenes too much
protests and a general strike prompted
Netanyahu to pause the legislation he's
promising to find a compromise with
opposition groups few here believe in
even President Biden doesn't believe him
nobody believes him even his own
Coalition doesn't believe him
and we think that now it's the most
dangerous time of all and we're very
worried that
um something we'll just uh they will
stop the negotiations just bring the law
to to vote the biggest you that they can
think about it is his future as in
addicted to uh country
the protesters are from across the
political Spectrum including supporters
from netanyahu's liquid party
Netanyahu on trial for corruption
charges he denies says the overhaul is
needed to balance the branches of
government
on Sunday Benjamin Netanyahu will hold
his last cabinet meeting before the
start of the Jewish Passover holiday
they'll of course have seen these
protests but in that meeting there will
be a lot of pressure from netanyahu's
far-right Coalition Partners to push on
with this attempt to overhaul Israel's
judiciary
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Tel Aviv
David saw is a former District commander
of the police in Tel Aviv he joins us
now live from Tel Aviv David good to
have you with us what's your view on the
formation of this new armed unit is it
needed is it even a good idea
well in general it's needed but not the
way that the minister and the government
was supposed to
approve it today I think
we need to strengthen the existing force
of the police which is lack of 2 000
police officers for uh in general for
regularly policing duties and it would
be blessed if they will add those this
budget and the police officers which
they want to
to do in this program but under the
commissioner and under the police it's
not only by the economic uh sense it's
also by the meaning that we can accept
that there will be any kind of law
enforcement which is not under the
regulation the law and in order of the
police commissioner and that's it I mean
it's very strange that the government
will decide to create another police
officers and as a your I think reporter
mentioned before
the concerns that it will be kind of a
private militia or it will be parallel
parallel to the existing forces to work
at the same territory with the different
commanding it will be a disaster
civil rights groups as we were hearing
have expressed concern fearing that this
unit could be misused from what you're
saying there you you share those
concerns
well definitely
was concerns but I can tell you that
there is some so many obstacles that it
won't happen I mean I'm so I think it's
part of the political uh
waves and issues that we're discussing
uh those in the last three months and um
I think you mentioned before the timing
of this decision came because of the
political crisis that the prime minister
is facing in his Coalition and the the
party of this minister
is put a lot of pressure because he
wants to uh gain some points in his base
on bringing this kind of a unit
um I think uh as the the head of the
shin bed the commissioner the legal
advisor everyone
told the the Prime Minister and the
government you could decide to strike
the existing force and we must say that
since 2021 that the crisis was where
that time in May which there was a huge
Uprising and then
a simultaneously
Uprising in demonstrations so this force
uh really really uh have a a big big
mission to uh to execute but it have to
be on the discipline of the police on
the civil rights of the police use using
Force only by the law and regulation so
that's that's a very very crucial issue
and actually the police already started
with that program like a year ago with
the former government and there are only
already like 900 police officers at that
unit some of them were existed before
and some of them were added after that
decision and some of the reserve units
which from coming from The Bodyguard
police have been located to that
National Guard unit okay and that can be
definitely been
executed by that organization David good
to talk to you many thanks indeed for
being with us David saw there